Again, thank you for the invitation, and we will continue our journey in marginal zone
lymphoma, and we will discuss genomic landscape specifically of extranodal marginal zone lymphoma.
So, as you know, extranodal marginal zone lymphoma is the most common marginal zone
lymphoma, accounting for 61% of the cases.
However, the mutational landscape of these extranodal marginal zone lymphoma cases has
been only evaluated in small number of patients, and mainly by targeted sequencing, because
most of these biopsies are usually very, very small or not accessible.
Consequently, the comprehensive genomic landscape of this disease is largely unknown in contrast
to many other lymphomas.
So, we analyzed 177 samples from 175 patients from 20 academic hematological departments.
We performed holoxone sequencing followed by targeted sequencing of 450 genes of potential
tumor drivers in 165 patients.
Copy number variation were examined in 84 patients.
RNA sequencing was performed in 159 patients.
This is the largest study also for this, not done previously.
Tumors from 17 locations were found, and that's also introduced heterogeneity.
And the most common anatomic locations were ocular adnexa, gastric, including H. pylori
positive and negative, salivary gland, and lungs.
We identified 1,000 patients.
2,218 variants across 174 genes, and 2,837 copy number of focal alterations.
Combining DNA mutations and copy number alterations, the number of genetic lesions per tumor samples
in the putative 174 putative driver genes averaged 25 per case, ranging from 0 to 102,
which is consistent with previous genetic studies in other subtypes of marginal zone
lymphoma, not all in specific.
Of these genes, 44 and 11 were mutated in 5 or more than 10% of the analyzed specimens
and may represent based on the nature of aberrations that were observed as driver genes.
This on-complete demonstrates the most commonly mutated genes found in more than 10%, 10 and
more, and you can see that the most common gene was H. pylori positive, salivary gland,
and the most common gene was H. pylori positive, salivary gland, which is consistent with previous genetic studies in other subtypes of marginal zone lymphoma.
The most common gene was H. pylori positive, salivary gland, which is consistent with previous genetic studies in other subtypes of marginal zone lymphoma.
When you do such analysis, you want to see if there are any genes that were previously
reported.
And we do observe the previously reported gene like A20, TNF-AAP, or the TBLXR1, ATM,
and NOTCH in SPEN.
We also observed new mutations in new genes that were previously not reported, for example,
like RUNX1.
In addition, new mutations were observed in transcriptional factor Z2, FAT4, and TNF-AAP.
Lipoprotein-1 receptor B, a gene that is mutated in many tumors but was not reported in this,
and others.
Mutation NKLF2 and mutation PTPRD7 were previously suggested to be specific for splenic and nodal
marginal zone lymphoma, but we could identify them also in extra nodal.
We identified gene fusions previously not reported in extra nodal marginal zone lymphoma.
I cannot describe them.
I will discuss it in seven minutes.
And importantly, previous studies suggested, based on small studies, that there is association
between certain mutations and expression of or usage of specific immunoglobulin genes.
In this large study, we confirmed that it's not correct, and there is no any association.
On this slide, we wanted to see what pathways are mainly affected.
The major pathways that were affected by mutation signature or Copenhaber variation.
These are the ones that were previously suggested to be altered.
However, interestingly, we observed also the DNA repair pathway is frequently affected in this disease, and mostly mismatch repair and homologous recombination with pathway.
And this is a summary of this.
So epigenetic chromatin pathway was the most commonly affected, 82%, DNA repair second, 69%, and the second most common.
much repair on homologous recombination pathway. And this is a summary of this. So epigenetic
chromatin pathway was the most commonly affected, 82%, DNA repair second, 69, notch 66, NF-kappa B
44, and B cell 40%. But most important clinical equations that will explain many of our clinical
observation, the simultaneous mutations affecting multiple pathways were observed in majority of
the tumors. So there is not a tumor with only B cell signaling pathway aberration. And that may
explain why when we're using PTK inhibitors in clinic, we're usually not getting higher rate of
complete remissions. We wanted to see if there are specific mutations in specific anatomical sites,
as was previously suggested. There was some enrichment in TT and FAP in ocular lymphoma,
as previously reported. But majority of the mutations, while they may occur,
with slightly different frequency in different sites, they are also present in other sites.
Here you see it for lung and ocular adnexa. And on the next slide, you see it for salivary gland
and gastric. ZEP2 is a new gene that was identified, previously was not reported.
It's transcriptional factor. And it was specifically observed only in gastric and salivary gland,
but the numbers are small, and this will need to be confirmed in future studies.
So as I already said, most mutations...
These mutations are observed without any relation to the specific site, with some exception of TNF-FAP3,
that is more commonly observed in ocular adnexa, and TET2 in thyroid, as previously reported.
The new mutation that we also observed was FAT4 mutation, and we observed it almost exclusively
in thyroid. And once again, but the numbers are small, and will need to be confirmed in the future.
We performed...
also gene expression. Previous studies only performed some gene expression in lung,
and there was really no studies across multiple sites.
So when we perform these studies in these tumors, we need to remember, this is not isolated cells,
so you have tumors from the organ of origin. So when we performed it, we observed some tendency
that the gastric was separated, but we couldn't understand if it's specific to the organ or not.
So we can see that it's not isolated. So it's not isolated. So we can see that it's not isolated.
We concentrated on 345 genes consisting of LM22 matrix, and this is a signature that is most
present in inflammatory cells and in immune cells. And what we observed, that in reality,
gastric lymphomas, this is in blue, cluster together irrespective of H. pylori positivity
or not positivity, while all the other tumors are spread out, and there is no clustering
by anatomic location. We observed specific activation of specific cells. So we can see that
it's not isolated. So we can see that it's not isolated. So we can see that it's not isolated.
So we can see that it's not isolated. So we can see that it's not isolated. So we can see that
So we can see that it's not isolated. So we can see that it's not isolated. So we can see that it's not isolated.
So we can see that it's not isolated. So we can see that it's not isolated. But once again,
in seven minutes, I cannot discuss. But then we wanted to see what's happening with immune
microenvironment. So the most commonly observed cells were mature B cells, they must probably
represent the tumor cells. We also observed presence of T cells and macrophages when we
wanted to see if there was differences between different locations. So we observed that mast cells
enriched statistically in stomach,
and macrophages were almost absent in stomach in contrast to the sites. And this is adjusted
for multiple hypothesis testing of the other inflammatory cells present in all the locations.
In conclusion, the broad genomic studies reported here underscore the biological similarity
of extranodal marginal zone lymphoma across anatomic sites,
with potential exception of gastric extranodal marginal zone lymphoma, regardless of HPL-rate
status.
This results indicate that the pathogenesis of extranodal marginal zone lymphoma
is likely to be strongly influenced by the marginal zone lymphoma B cell lineage
than the anatomic location, even though anatomic locations may influence the composition of the
tumor and microenvironment. Simultaneous mutations affecting multiple pathway
may either then lie resistant of targeted therapies that were observed in clinic.